during the summer
in Manchester
I described our new prime minister
as an action woman
she campaigned as a conservative and now
she's governing as a conservative
[Applause]
she promised to deliver deliver
so conference
she promised us lower corporation tax
did she deliver
she promised us that she'd tackle Energy
prices did she deliver
and she promised to reverse the National
Insurance increase for every single
working household in this country this
month did she deliver
Ed there you have it
conference
we all fondly remember another great
female prime minister
who like to say to the EU no no no no
watch out Sir Humphrey
you've just got the yes yes yes prime
minister
[Applause]
but conference we're here today because
there's so much more to be done
and let me tell you
if we had to keep delivering to Britain
if we're going to keep it free of the
scourge of socialism the left-wing
business as usual Orthodoxy we simply
cannot afford to be divided
because United
we will ensure that our prime minister
will take on the labor party at the next
general election and win
and in less than two years
we're going to be asking our country to
decide between two Stark alternatives
we served to Britain
one we've set out at our conference this
week
a conservative Britain that supports
businesses
so firms can get on and pay higher wages
to their employees
a conservative Britain
that enables families to keep more of
their own money in their pocket so they
can decide what they spend their money
on rather than living paycheck to
paycheck
and a conservative Britain that is on
your side
when you are faced with increased energy
bills
the alternative
a labor vision
a big state
on the side of vested interests and the
union Barons who are determined to make
your life a misery
taking more of your hard-earned cash out
of the hand of your family
and I tell you children
as the father of three small children
under five
I know what country I want my kids to
grow up in and that's why for our
country's sake we need to deliver for
our prime minister
but to deliver that conservative Britain
we've got to realize
there are three huge challenges facing
us
three challenges that we must stand up
to as a party
strongly and with our vision that family
is know best for themselves
firstly
the labor party
the labor party call themselves
Progressive
in fact they now claim to be the
political wing of the British people
but we know it's the same old labor
party
no plan for growth no plan for jobs no
plan to help the British people with
their energy bills
they're led by KIA Stormer these are
short of low energy Neil kinnick
without a plan it's all the Care and no
idea
and Conference the really scary thing
is the labor party and labor activists
now talk about themselves as the
government in waiting
and we know it's our job as
conservatives to keep them waiting a
very long time
the Second Great challenge
the lip Dems
according to the chattery chattering
classes the lib Dem Revival is now well
underway
that conference I ask you
looking at the finest political Minds
available in Great Britain
can any of you name four libbed mmps
all 11 of them
but the real danger is their labor light
they are willing to work with the
separatists in Scotland the SMP they
will prop up a dangerous big state
strike-ridden government that is intent
on destroying our United Kingdom
and the lip Dems also tell me
they have the best local campaigners in
the country
do we think that's true
of course not
because from Mary Robinson and cheedle
to Alex Chalk in Cheltenham it is the
conservatives who are knocking on
millions of doors armed with our message
that we have delivered and we will
continue to deliver for our country and
our community
and lastly
our greatest challenge
the people who love to talk Britain down
the moment it was announced that
taxpayers would keep more of their money
they're off
the doomsayers the naysayers they were
out on the media fresh back from holiday
from talking down brexit armed with the
argument that only the big state will do
business
keeping more of their own money so they
can give their staff a pay rise
that will never do
investment zones attracting new
desperately needed private investment to
areas that lead need leveling up no just
send more men from the ministry and hope
for the best
so instead of that negativity
as a conservative party we say trust the
British people
let them decide what to do with their
money business understands better than
Whitehall how to create growth we want
public services that work for us
not just the trade unions
so conference it's our job to be
relentless in delivery over the next two
years
and I promise you
as chairman of the conservative party I
will do whatever it takes to win the
next election
but our greatest asset
is our new prime minister
Liz truss
will unite and level up our country
she is the woman who will get Britain
moving and Britain will win thank you
please welcome the chancellor of the
duchy of Lancaster Nadeem sahawi
foreign
conference it's uh great to be back
surrounded by the friends and of course
at the Beating Heart of the conservative
family
I want to tell you a bit about what
brought me here today
because it's been a long way from
Baghdad to Birmingham
as many of you know I was born in
Sudan's Iraq and age 11.
I was given an impossibly precious gift
a new start
in a new country
a country where the good kind devoted
head of state cut ribbons and organized
Garden parties not endless parades of
tanks and missiles
and growing up in this wonderful country
I wanted nothing to do with politics
because for me politics meant fear
politics
was a door kicked off its hinges in the
middle of the night
the unmarked van
the muffled scream
in a government cell
so when I got to University and first
encountered politics my instinct was to
keep well clear
I remember on my one of my first days at
University College London
at the freshest fair in fact a lefty
student came up and offered me a copy of
the Socialist Workers Party magazine I
very politely declined and tried to move
on
you race traitor he shouted at me
right in my face
so I thought to myself what could I do
what could I do that will really rather
spoke up
How can I
how can I really get under his skin
and the answer was obvious I immediately
marched over to the UCL conservative
stand and asked them to sign me up
and Boom at that moment I was hooked on
politics
so since then like many of you and like
our amazing new prime minister I've been
a local councilor I spent three terms as
a Borough counselor in Wandsworth that
Flagship low tax Council that I know we
will win back in a few years time
I built a Great British business
and thanks to the conservative and
unionist party the boy from Baghdad is
now the Member of Parliament for
Shakespeare and holds the wonderfully
Arcane title of Chancellor of the duchy
of Lancaster
and just last month in my second day in
the job it became the privilege of my
life
to deliver the commemorations to her
late Majesty's funeral 1100 talented
civil servants from across government
the police the Armed Forces even
politicians all pulling in One Direction
and delivering a fitting farewell to
Elizabeth the Great
and Conference next year we will do it
all over again for his Majesty's
coronation in what other country in what
other country I ask you
in what other country I ask you would
someone like a scared 11 year old boy
from Iraq be able to do that
I've been
lucky enough to have my British dream
come true
my friends
it's our sacred mission to help our
fellow britons realize their British
dream as well
we will always be the party of
aspiration and achievement and the left
hate that about us
they can't stand that we exist to help
people make the most of their lives to
go as far as their talents will take
them to make the world a better place to
pass on to their children and
grandchildren to earn their own success
they can't stand it this year I was
lucky enough
to have the ultimate summer job
that of Chancellor of the exchecking
but in all seriousness
um my stint and her and his Majesty's
treasury reinforced a lesson that I
already knew from business the
chancellor of the exchequer is the
government's Chief Financial Officer
those of you uh in business uh in the
audience and at home will understand
that the CFO needs to be an enabler they
need to help empower the decisions of
the CEO and the whole team in this case
to help people to make the most of their
opportunities and under my old friend
quasi quateng armed with our ambitious
growth plan this treasury will be an
enabler an opportunity Unblocker a job
and growth creator
conference as the new Minister for
intergovernmental relations I'd also
like to draw special attention to our
beloved Union
I don't need to tell the conservative
and universe party of the importance of
the Union
the bond of our four nations isn't a
soulless contract
a mere fiscal transfer it is a covenant
a bond forged hundreds of years before
asahawi even set foot on these Shores it
has endured throughout the toughest of
times and our nation has faced and it
must end will endure
as a proud person
as a proud Britain I feel the bond of
England Wales Scotland and Northern
Ireland in the marrow of my bones I know
that you all do too
we also know that this Union needs
constant renewal so instead of seeding
the field to narrow-minded nationalists
let's talk up the opportunity that the
union provides the security it brings in
times of trouble the bright future that
our Island Story promises for all
today we should ask ourselves this
question
what would Vladimir Putin prefer
a strong confident United Kingdom able
to project power across Europe
or a divided house squabbling amongst
itself obsessed with the question of
identity
this time last week I chaired a meeting
of the new islands Forum in far-flung
orkney
those fine people are
not served by constitutional squabbles
about Scotland's future
they are served by certainty that the
union of the United Kingdom Under a new
king and with a conservative
Administration provides them
so in this Hall today
let us reaffirm from orkney to Cornwall
our Union will endure and Thrive under
this renewed shared purpose
in a similar vein I want to talk a
little bit about another part of my
portfolio the equalities brief
as the party of the family we know that
families come in all shapes and sizes it
was a conservative government that
legalized same-sex marriage because Love
Is Love
because because it's the individual not
the state who gets to decide who we fall
in love with and inspired by our belief
in the individual this government is
firm that LGBT people should be free to
live their lives as they wish and love
who they want
I've
I've suffered my fair share of prejudice
growing up
but I also know
that Britain is one of the least racist
countries on Earth
the British people are more concerned
about treating everyone with dignity
respect and fairness than any other
people on earth
we aren't perfect there's always more to
do
but instead of wasting taxpay's
hard-earned cash indulging shrill
lefties we must redouble our focus on
changing and improving lives
now here's a sobering stat conference
over 63 000 girls excel in maths in
primary schools every single year
but by the time they get to sixth form
fewer than 4 000 of them will take
further maths at a level
imagine what Britain would be like
if our concern for equality led us to
producing tens of thousands of female
mathematicians every year instead of
trying to placate the placard waivers
and the woke Warriors
[Applause]
is the most precious thing in my life
she turned 10 this past weekend and I
want her to have the same opportunity
her big brothers had equality of
opportunity means real benefits and not
only for women and girls but for our
society and economy as a whole it is my
fervent commitment that no one's Destiny
is determined by their background
foreign
for women in this country I want to talk
about our new prime minister
a third woman prime minister of this
country has had and the third
conservative woman prime minister at
that
labor
all talk but all we see is trousers
let me let me just give you an insight
into how the Prime Minister operates you
may have read that she does her box work
and hosts meetings at the cabinet table
with papers all around her and her
Fantastic Team by her side our new prime
minister has total Clarity of what she
wants to happen
she has the laser-like focus that is a
prerequisite of a great CEO
and crucially she knows her own mind
she has told me what she wants to
deliver and she has asked me to oversee
that delivery effectively as the Chief
Operating Officer of this Administration
and being no doubt conference this
government will share that same
laser-like focus and it will deliver on
the tangible things that really matter
to the British people
what does the delivery really mean it
means actually getting the job done
it's been a constant strength of a
conservative Administration down the
years but I have to say all too often
now it's become just another political
buzzword
so let me bring to life what Britain
will actually look like in a few years
time when this government has delivered
on its pledges
delivery looks like swella breatherman
in the home office getting illegal
migrants on planes to Rwanda
tackling the criminal gangs
tackling those evil criminal gangs
bringing people over on small boats
bringing down crime with more Bobbies on
the beat policing real crimes and not
policing free speech delivery looks like
Ben Wallace
delivery looks like Ben Wallace in
defense keeping Britain safe developing
more advanced defense systems putting
more weapons in the hands of Brave
ukrainians and standing up to puta's
barbaric illegal War
delivery delivery looks like our amazing
new Deputy Prime Minister Therese coffee
in health tackling the problems facing
our NHS with her ABCD priorities
ambulances backlogs care doctors and
dentists
delivery looks like Jacob Reese smog in
the business and energy Department
galvanizing the energy industry and
making sure your bills are lower and of
course along with Simon Clark bringing
investment zones to every corner of our
country delivering well-paid jobs
developing those new technologies of the
future and it looks like kit Morehouse
Kip Moore has an education making sure
that your children and grandchildren
have skills they need to get an on in
life vocational of course as well as
academic delivery looks like my old
friend Brandon Lewis and Justice
clearing the Court's covered backlog and
seeing that Justice is done and is seen
to be done and of course delivery
delivery is Anne retrovalian in
transport getting Spades in the ground
for New Roads to get Britain moving
delivery looks like Kenny badenoff an
international trade signing more of
those trade deals helping businesses
export more products and services around
the world and I could go on and on and
on
that's an amazing program of government
my friends we will focus on delivering
all of that
and when we do we will blow labor out of
the water
and we will secure that historic fifth
conservative term in office for the
Prime Minister and this amazing
conservative and unionist party
and crucially
crucial
we will make lives better for our fellow
britons up and down the country
the greatest country on Earth
[Applause]